what would you say is a legacy you and  your dad want to leave when it's all  said and done is chasing purpose worth  the pain in hindsight god bless that's a  good question so i've actually thought  about this before because i was so sick  for so long and diet helped me i'm  hoping that by the time i die when you  go to the doctor for a lifestyle disease  like obesity diabetes this type of  things the first line of treatment is  uh diet rather than here's a medication  because i'd rather not be known as like  beef girl or like be the beef girl  person  it's like yeah but it's not like that  that's part of the reason i started a  podcast was like i got to get out of  this i don't want to be like the  carnivore person yeah um but the reason  i still talk about it is because i'm  hoping that it'll actually make some  change with the medical system because i  mean people are so sick like one in five  people are on a psychiatric medication  everybody has weight problems and it's  sad